okay um a few other updates here
south dakota has seen cases quintuple
quintuple quintuple
after the sturgis
motorcycle rally
two weeks after the annual motorcycle
rally in sturgis south dakota reported
covet infections in the state have risen
nearly six-fold it's a very unsurprising
headline
south dakota counted more than 3 800 new
cases in two weeks including seven
deaths
up from only 644 cases in the previous
two weeks
that makes it the state with the largest
percent increase
in covid in the past two weeks the
state's rate of covet infections per
capita in the last two weeks in is in
the bottom half of the country but it's
the sharp and sudden increase in case
counts that sets it apart meade county
home to sturgis has counted 330 new
cases in the last two weeks this is a
really low population place so 330 cases
is a lot up from the 20 reported in the
two weeks before the rally so look think
about that number
the two weeks before the rally meade
county has 20 coveted cases
in the two weeks after the rally meade
county has
330 coveted cases that's according to
the johns hopkins university case count
the 1550 percent increase comes after
the motorcycle rally which usually draws
half a million people possibly had its
biggest year ever according to county
sheriff ron merwin
and as you can see we're putting up a
map on the screen and i'll describe the
map to you the map is of all 50 u.s
states and what you see is that there is
one dark red state that stated south
dakota
and that is where we have seen a 493
percent increase over two weeks some of
the other darker red states include
nearby north dakota up about 124 percent
west virginia which is up uh i'm not
exactly sure what percent
um indiana is looking pretty red up
about 99
and the lightest color states california
and nevada as well as missouri and
louisiana so that's what's going on
there and it is a completely
unsurprising headline uh there's also
the question of whether we're going to
see similar numbers um in alabama
remember donald trump on saturday
holding a rally in coleman alabama
and
alabama
the worst slash second to worse
health infrastructure
in the united states
education is also terrible in
mississippi and alabama
vaccination rates are very low in
mississippi and alabama and so we'll see
whether we're going to get more cases
there now i know some of you will be
saying hold on a second david sir
you always talk about how outdoors is
really not a big deal
and mostly that is correct as we've
talked about even before we had vaccines
only about one out of a thousand coveted
cases was being transmitted outdoors
um but that one out of a thousand was
happening when people were doing
obviously stupid things that they
shouldn't be doing like massing together
by the thousands and so if you are going
to see case transmission outdoors it's
going to be in situations
like the trump rally in coleman alabama
where nobody was wearing masks people
were masked together for some people got
their 12 hours 10 9 10 hours before the
rally
and we're gonna see we'll track the
numbers two weeks before and two week
after two weeks after trump's rally in
alabama but it is not looking good and
people doing
really dumb things and i don't expect it
to change anytime soon sadly